i'm just
playing i'm just right you know are you
constantly trying to is it is it
difficult for you or are you thinking
about
trying to outdo yourself for the next
one
like like this outfit was great he loved
it the audience loved it now are you
worried or concerned about trying to
up the level of outre or how make
the next costume more outrageous or
buoyant here's the answer
it's it's in two parts and the two parts
are
a
you're making so many outfits you don't
have that much time to think
so think worry
criticize yourself whatever you're going
to buy fabric
you're cutting up the fabric you're
trying this with it trying that with it
you're telling vera put it do it this
way do it that way
you know fiora sometimes she doesn't get
i'm writing a note
do this this and this on this she
doesn't sometimes understand michael
what the hell he wanted she does
something else
maybe it's cooler maybe it's cooler
um but in general
there's no time to do it you're just
trying to make cool clothes
each week each month you're
trying to use all the parts so
we're talking about holographic glitter
on
you know these right here or you're
talking about
here's these are painted then some of
the stuff is painted and then the
glitters put on top of the paint
um i don't know if any of it's here
these are rhinestones
that are glued on there um here's
rhinestones that have been banged off
you know as rough as he is you know with
the outfit so
i'm just saying to you that there's no
time for it there's just a time to
to do what you're doing go buy the
fabric chop
it up give it to vera talk with
in that shop is glasses being made i
mean i got pictures of maybe
15 or 20 pair of glasses on a board
being made at the same time
where i'm painting the edges of the
glasses or i'm putting the
the glitter on i'm more than i'm
painting this
but there's all these they're lined up
in rows and rows i'm painting lots of
glasses
um but my point is is that
in doing this i'm seeing that
the business of trying to do it
as well as i can is made worse
by the distraction of well this is going
to be on television this is
macho man this is this is just another
guy meaning i'm just trying to do the
best that i can
with the parts again that are in front
of me
and what do you mean it's made worse
it's distracted i'm my creative
or my work ethic is distracted
by the attention by the
loss of breath because of who this
person is
okay yeah there's lots of way to say it
okay that's what you're saying i'm just
they're expecting
something i'm expecting something
tony is expecting me to make clothes
that's what i do
and the story is no more to it there's
no romance to it
it's business you know and so then i
could see
oh i gotta go fix that buttonhole
machine these buttonholes aren't right
or
i need you know a thousand pearl buttons
where am i gonna get them from i gotta
fly
to new york and then go to new jersey
and find
someone that's making you know one-inch
pearl buttons and i'll buy seconds and
shift through and not use the bad ones
or whatever
um so there's just so much of
time that is eaten up with the actual
work of the thing
that you get away from
[Music]
the side ideas of this person's famous
on account of or
this person went to jail for whatever or
you know meaning these are all just
humans i learned this
as a little kid oh
mindy there's a there was a couple
named lance a bear
and his wife lived in saint peter's a
sax player in a band
keyboard player songwriter
um had a daughter had a baby
whatever in the 70s and
she became a sax player that's known
mindy a bear a b a i r
i think i'm spelling it right anyway she
calls me on the phone she says listen i
live in l.a
i mean and i obviously remember her and
i know the parents for a thousand years
i live in a i live in la the guy that
makes my clothes i showed him a pair of
pants that you made from my father
in the 70s
he and i needed him to be altered to fit
me
he told me he wouldn't touch him this is
he never saw anything like this in his
life
it's the mechanics of it the whole thing
is in another place
so i said when you come to florida come
i'll do them
so i i we
took the pants apart put them back
together where they would fit her and
all that
um and she wore them on american idol
and all that
and took all kind of pictures in them
but all i'm saying to you is that
do i know how to sew yes um am i glad to
do a job like
that for her for no money yeah
of course but my point is is that
this whole emotional
thing about seeing it on television or
on album cover
it's not there it may just be me it may
just be my i don't know what to tell you
it may be how i needed to see this whole
thing in order to get through it
if i was spending time you know that
this jimi hendrix outfit
i didn't like the way it looked or jimmy
ripped it
or the audience didn't like it or they
didn't use it for the album cover
you know whatever it's a different place
i would be and maybe a
you know i mean it's it's also
the most tremendous incredible marketing
you could have had for yourself
it's it's you potentially would not have
been as successful if you were if jimi
hendrix wasn't
a international superstar rock and roll
musician you know what i mean like
my story is i say well
if you're making clothes for god in
those days
you know you're just saying well i'm
making god's clothes you know so
you know that's you no one can say
anything you know they say
you're into name dropping you know and
you understand what name dropping is and
you know some nashville musician i can't
think of who it is he says
yeah paul mccartney told me i shouldn't
name drop you know or some kind of thing
like that he was making the joke meaning
this is a big deal but you're saying you
may close for jimi hendrix or
this guy that i'm taking you to make
clothes for jimin
i